super
ah tiens mignon ce soir lernout j'ai
besoin de me retrouver seule avec elle
j'ai vraiment envie que ça fonctionne
qui est de l'amour j'ai hâte de lui
montrer ma personnalité or s'il ya un
truc vraiment discret l'alchimie
traitement alors s est vrai que la
chambre est la chambre mais témoin la
chambre la chambre et les races et moi
je alors moi différences
passées mais j valera sera là je vois
comment votre charme alertera regarder
le dis sans rigoler on dirait le leap
year
déconner frères attend c'est quoi ce
lille a les pieds des pinceaux devant
mais c'est sur la yole dada les gars qui
sont
ckoi solide à oui juste en tant que
spécialiste ès windows en effet 4
maintenant c'est rien c'est un mythe et
vous êtes fier jamais grand chose parce
que ça c'est vous êtes en semaine non
mais franchement c'est un 1000e par n'y
va pas on va pas face et pas la nuit de
noces ou à découvrir sa femme et wafa
est malade et
qu'il a remis des miracles
non franchement c'est généralement
catastrophique banal nan mais vous
toujours 80
sauf que là l'émission c'est quand même
on l'avait déjà dit c'est mario premier
crevard il attend tous une chose c'est
de finir dans le même lit c'est un lit
complètement
j'attends un peu avant de trouver mon
lieu mais voilà au moins je
sais que la sar est un truc de ouf ben
tout ou non et nous chaque jour est une
nuise à
wen va bien et ça c'est vraiment le
discours d'une mission pour
ça le gêne que la production force les
candidats dormir ensemble le premier
soir et je pense qu'il y en a et ce en
france en mai grave marié se connaissent
pas c'est le format de l'émission
estivale plus ou moins qu'une émission
de dating avec des gens qui veulent
passer à la télé ça me gêne parce que je
pense qu'il ya des gens qui se force à
coucher pour l'émission mais ça serait
bien que guillaume travaille un peu ses
dossiers marsa puisque l'ajustement
caroline elle ne dort pas avec lui elle
va dans la chambre à côté mais le
guillaume cote a rien à dire tu fais
comme agen battu sa gueule
[Applaudissements]
celle-ci maginez déjà passé une nuit de
folie d'arrêt n'est pas du tout dans le
même délire c'est faux dit il aussi
je ne sens pas du tout de partager la
chambre ce soir
[Musique]
ils font pas la belle
j'étais alors c'est ma mère qui m'écrit
qui me met on dirait le lit de ta soeur
ollila
pourquoi elle dit oui si elle veut pas
faire crac avec lui dans maman
mariage est mariée au premier regard
alors c'est pas un mariage mariage nuit
de noce 9 croco non mais parce que
j'étais trop là dedans c'est la vérité
on l'a bien vu quand elle dit oui elle
était trop polie elle n'a pas osé dire
oui parce qu'elle soit là il lui plaît
pas ça ne plaît pas assez la soirée dont
s'est déroulée la salle et moi sur le
dialyse pas dans le délire alors bon
foutu pour foutu donc axé là tout de
suite a promis un plan b pour se
remonter le moral vous allez voir il
peut très bien s'occuper tout seul ce
garçon
et emmener demain tu vas te coucher part
en tant qu'homme marié en fait ce soir
beaucoup première seul je pense que je
triturer soir et cette nuit je veux pas
prendre une décision hâtive maintenant
[Applaudissements]
non mais le court et il est là c'est ma
faute mais qui vient de se marier quand
même temps tu as nast avec là le noeud
papillon et où tu dors tout seul comme
un mode pour moi tu dors avec ta meuf
studio où on regarde je suis pas mort
car audi ne touche pas mon possible
mais au moins dans miami
moi je peux grave dans mais avec des
meufs sans rien faire
j'étais sans pour evans bien avec mes
cheveux d'anvers plein de faux avec des
meufs sans rien c'est des mecs
non non non mais c'est vrai mais
franchement mais attendez ça va me
dormir avec sa femme et voilà l amf ils
apprennent à se connaître
regardez gilles ça fait 30 ans qu'ils
dorment ensemble il ya bruno et alicia
aussi qu'ils sont partis à la découverte
de porto portugal viendrait lui à porto
sur l'autre
étant d'origine portugaise bruno n'a pas
pu s'empêcher dû faire une petite visite
guidée de la ville pour lui raconter
plein de trucs super intéressant sauf
que clairement alicia elle son ballet
total
c'est le carnage convient aux mureaux
ben khedda fado c'est une ch'ti mousse
call portugais ah ouais ouais chaque
fois que tu t'en la tête tu vois une
église c'est fou une deux trois là bas 4
assez important en fait et plusieurs
niveaux et là on est en partie ok
d'accord encore du carrelage record du
carnage au mur vous avez un bon budget
pour carrelage
en tout cas une chose est sûre c'est que
bruno lui il a bien profité de cette
petite visite pour avoir les mains
baladeuses regard je vais appréhender je
disais ça peut paris je suis pas je peux
me dire quoi
qui ne met pas au fond mon mari
[Musique]
on va faire un tour ok d'accord
non mais franchement
tu ne mets pas les mots
ils ont besoin de tricher
turquie gauche ensemble timité d'une
chaumont fallait qu'il promène pas
à toi ce que ça te dérange non elle a
pas l'air de se plaindre à bastille syed
ahmad al ahram en
quoi ils s'embrassent ça va pas